[Music]  looking for you what are we what if I  told you there's a place where people  have powers like us city of Adeline and  I can take you there  we're Inhumans  [Music]  maybe I'm foolish maybe I'm blind  and you na can see through this and left  behind brother sooner or later the  humans are going to find it got no way  to prove it so maybe I'm not the first  course of action will be to try to  destroy one how only you after Rama we  need to go to hers now we need to strike  first  it would only lead to war are you  speaking for yourself or for our King  [Music]  Maximus is trying to take over aniline  are you going to kill your only brother  i'ma leave after honor me imagine you  came after all don't put the blame on me  never don't put your blame on me you're  just a human  you